d'hamilton bonsoir alors vous n'avez pas
froid la non tout va bien c'est quand
vous écrivez vous crever de froid est un
excellent jeu
gardez vos mitaines c'est pas parce que
vous avez froid c'est le
porte-jarretelles de la main à le portel
de la main très bien ça commence fort
alors il ya plein de plein de trucs en
promo là il ya le sabotage amoureux donc
été un roman faisait publier en 93 qui
remontait sur scène au théâtre du
ranelagh adapté par un label milot et
pascal lissy lourd avec valérie mairesse
alors valérie mairesse vous l'avez connu
quand quand vous êtes allé chez laurent
ruquier en effet ce mois de septembre
pour l'apparition de mercure j'ai
rencontré valérie mairesse qui m'a dit
tiens je suis en train d'étudier votre
texte parce qu'on monte la pièce de
sabotage amoureux moi je suis tombé des
nues je préviens nouvelle je n'en savais
rien pour vous dire à quel point je n'y
suis pour rien oui bah d'ailleurs alors
vous l'avez vu hier soir pour la
première fois j'étais vierge jusqu'à
hier soir et alors ses sensations et
c'est vrai vous êtes contents non
sérieusement je m'attendais au pire
sincèrement pour moi on n'avait aucune
chance de réussir c'est un livre qui
n'avait aucune chance d'être adapté au
théâtre c'est de la narration c'est
surréaliste on nous a dit non en gros
l'argument du livre c'est un souvenir
d'enfance ça se passe à pékin de 72 à 75
c'est une guerre enfantine est le récit
d'un premier amour avec la petite
italienne
serena oui c'est ça cyniquement jeu ça
me paraissait promis au désastre mais la
mise en scène est tellement
incroyablement ingénieuse que cette
fabuleuse tout le monde est très poussée
est contente fuite forcée au théâtre du
ray au théâtre du ranelagh donc pas y
aller un seuil et la maintenance et
c'est sur scène c'est parti et que notre
amie valérie mairesse voilà alors ça
c'est la pièce oui après il ya le film
dans le film il tirait de votre premier
roman qui s'appelait hygiène de
l'assassin donc été en 92 et nous on a
enfin un aperçu ici jean claude dreyfus
qui était inquiété par lille était allé
voir la pièce à l'époque donc là c'est
un film qui a été fait par françois
ruggeri oui avec jean yanne c'est ça oui
ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec la
pièce jouée par dreyfus qui ont passé
c'est encore tout à fait autre chose
ici on peut le dire on est assez loin du
roman de dub avoue d'ailleurs dire il ya
écrit librement trahi
j'ai créé pour les besoins de la cause
une nouvelle formule juridique j'avais
l'intention de bien m'entendre avec
françois ruggeri qu'est l'homme le plus
charmant du monde
son scénario vraiment me poser de
problème parce que le rap le lien de
parenté
avec mon livre est très floue mais
vraiment très flou et alors je lui ai
dit écoute si tu veux qu'on s'entende
bien
j'exige que tu crées pour moi une
nouvelle formule juridique qui figurera
aussi bien sur le contrat que sur le
livre montre librement trahi de à la
place de vraiment adapté deux je me
demande si la formule fait rage ici
c'est bien ben ça c'est aussi ça fera
école parce que c'est généralement le
cas alors il ya jean yahia barbara
schulz qu'on voit dans les portes du
ciel de jacques attali avec depardieu en
ce moment sur scène alors on dit tout
l'argument enfin on avait beaucoup parlé
avec dreyfus ici mais dit tout quoi il
retourne quoi c'est ce vieux prix nobel
c'est un vieux prix nobel de littérature
mourant il n'a plus que pour deux mois à
vivre et il décide comme dernier
divertissement de s'offrir une
journaliste a démoli
comme passe temps seulement il tombe sur
une dure à cuire qui est la petite
barbara schulz qui est ma tante et ça va
donner une joute verbale voile alors
troisième chose vous mais pas pour rien
quand vous venez vous troisième chose
ils livrent donc mercure qui est sorti
en septembre qui marche très très bien
oui mais nous en dire un mot comme ça
pour eux très difficile d'en parler
parce que c'est un livre qui est
entièrement par plus construit à partir
d'une imposture verbale c'est un trucage
pour la première fois j'ai vraiment
écrit avec un trucage
du coup si j'en parle de trucage ses
fondations
on achète tant l'ia c'est chez albin
michel voilà alors bâti dont 1
alors vous êtes un personnage étonnant
vous avez fait irruption dans l'est dans
les médias français
il ya quoi il ya sept ans maintenant six
ans s'il en est vrai oui c'est ça et
vous vous êtes effectivement tailler une
place parce que vous êtes un personnage
très particulier d'abord vous venez
d'une famille qui en france ne connaît
pas bien mais en belgique la famille nos
tombes
c'est quelque chose c'est ça qui est
merveilleux c'est être publiés en france
les trois quarts des français et me
demande pourquoi j'ai choisi ce
pseudonyme étrange et pas combien leurs
questions et rafraîchissante
parce que c'est vrai qu'en belgique
c'est un nom à ces lois connues bien sûr
c'est là il ya en 1830 au moment de la
création de la belgique le type qui a
écrit la constitution s'appelait notre
âme celle du mans c'est à dire que la la
la belgique résulte de la coalition de
dix familles ont pu dire qui chacune ont
apporté une partie de leur territoire
l'extrême sud est de la belgique a été
apportée par des notes en voilà c'est
affreusement lourd à porter alors vous
aviez vous aviez annoncé au travers
grand père s'appelait pierre oui alors
qu'ils étaient un personnage intéressant
qui est un poète chrétien qui avait
fondé l'action nationale qu'un peu
comparé à l'action française vous pouvez
imaginer comme ce nom est tu rapportes
il paraît comme c'est arrivé à
l'université
les gens vous regardez avec un air un
peu consterné d'autant plus que moi je
n'étais au courant de rien oui vu que je
signais en extrême orient j'ai grandi
wissem orient et mes parents avaient eu
le bon goût de ne rien ça vient ça
voulait dire c'est parce qu'il était
absolument pas je suis arrivé pour la
première fois en europe à 17 ans à
bruxelles pour aller à l'université sans
nom mais dites moi il n'a rien fait de
mal quand même si il n'a rien fait de
mal non est ce qu'il est et rexiste il
l'a probablement été mais non en même
temps non parce qu'il était beaucoup
trop chrétiens pour ça oui les
réactionnaires donc c'est des gens qui
chausse particulier on de grèzes gens un
peu extrême droite un peu comme ça
non il a il a dit beaucoup de choses il
a écrit beaucoup de choses il n'a rien
fait il voulait lui voulait faire la
grande belgique ans assez rigolo damas
un projet de deux c'est plus grave que
ça il voulait créer un empire
catholiques d'europe dont il se serait
bien vu enfin parce qu'il était assez
mégalo qui serait allée de la flandre à
venise
ah ouais d'accord oui c'est là la
lotharingie de l'exacte angleterre fils
fils de charlemagne dois je préciser que
je ne me descend désolidarise totalement
de tous ses points de vue bien sûr mais
enfin bon en même temps si vous
commencez votre inventaire quoi je n'ai
jamais connu je suis né en 67 joué il ya
plein de gens pensent aujourd'hui au
gouvernement quant à lui des parents
collaborateurs et voilà ils sont
socialistes mais pas de problème le vous
l'avez lu son bouquin le prince de old
time non j'ai lu l'un de ses livres ne
serait ce que pour ce livre là je ne
rougis pas totalement d'être son arrière
petite fille il est le seul écrivain au
monde à avoir écrit un roman de
science-fiction catholique
c'est à dire que ça s'appelle la
rédemption de mars
c'est l'histoire d'un missionnaire qui
prend une fusée pour aller sur la
planète mars dans l'idée d'évangéliser
les martiens était bien allumer votre
grand père c'est qui est magnifique
c'est qu'il n'y parvient pas il
voilà il ya grand père était torturé par
la chair et son missionnaire qui va sur
la planète mars
ces combos zappa d'une très belle
martienne et se termine par une scène
d'amour entre le missionnaire et la
belle dans cette famille l'imagination
alors bon vous êtes né au japon vous
effectuez on n'était pas au courant de
tout ça de suite naco b votre père était
ambassadeur votre père c'est quelqu'un
mais c'est quand même le seul européen
qui sait chanter le nom c'est la seule
non japonais au monde à chanter
professionnellement le novice et les
pousse michel c'est une famille à quoi
alors la bombe toute votre enfance était
un peu bringuebalé 1 comme les enfants
l'ambassadeur vous déménagez tous les
trois ans en chine au laos birmanie
bangladesh et on la seule chose
finalement que vous retrouvez de
d'escale en escale c'est un peu la
bibliothèque de vos parents quoi c'est
ça paradoxalement quand si on lis mes
livres on pourrait se dire avec
l'enfance qu'elle a eu ça va être
tellement exotique du tout se sont
recontrés revirement très axé sur le
langage parce que très vite fait de
remarquer que j'ai compris que la seule
identité que j'avais à travers tout ce
déracinement
c'était le langage quand j'avais lu les
mais les misérables à l'âge de 9 ans
quand même y avait une part de pause
dans tous sens oui à bord et je voulais
poser à 9 ans alors vous vous ai
commencé à écrire très jeune hygiène de
l'assassin qui est le premier bouquin
publié en france en fait c'était je
crois le dixième laurence ancien bleu
11e' le 11e alors bon vous écrivez ce
bouquin vous l'envoyer par la poste oui
vous l'envoyer chez deux éditeur chez
gallimard et chez albin michel un oui
alors sollers vous réponds je n'aime pas
les canulars
oui mais bon là il a perdu une affaire
là mais moi je suis je remercie très
chaleureusement sollers parce que je
suis tellement contente d'être chez
albin michel
quand même grâce à lui quoi oui bah oui
finalement oui là il doit se mordre les
doigts quand ils vous croiser dans les
cocktails vous vendez beaucoup de livres
maintenant oui mais il affecte de ne pas
me reconnaître mais tout va très bien
beaucoup solaire enfin ça se fait pas
alors bon alors hygiène de l'assassin
donc sorti en 92 après une sortie un
parent il ya eu le sabotage amoureux
donc et la pièce avec valérie mairesse
et au ranelagh en ce moment les
combustibles en 94 les catilinaires en
95 est alors prêt ya attentats en 97 et
mercure en croatie et alain qui oublié
dans votre biographie hameau de
bibliographie qui est transmise par
albin michel donc c'est pas s'est pas
tapé c'est péplum qu'elles n'ont pas pas
pour ce soir je dis pas bien peuple j'en
sais rien mais vous venez de m'apprendre
non parce qu'à l'époque la critique
avait dit que c'était bavard et
interminable
mais la critique a dit à mon sujet tout
et son contraire je peux vous le trouver
pour n'importe lequel de mes livres
autant de partisans que des tracts dans
des blâmes c'est pas vous qui leur avait
dit on ne mettait plus d'arrivants
abiola non pas moi j'aurais aimé tous
mes enfants très bien que ça fait oui ça
en fait un paquet d'avants alors cette
épreuve
vous avez beaucoup de succès non
seulement en france mais dans d'autres
pays du g 13 buts en 18 langues 18
langues et en allemagne depuis le grand
prix des libraires
j'aime bien traverser un succès
populaire passe et pas seulement 16 ans
bien alors vous avez écrite contre 40
bouquin 7 publié mais je suis en train
d'écrire le 36e si sa folie
mais grâce aux mânes cause d'une maladie
que vous avez c'est un peu une maladie
mais c'est une maladie qui me fait jouer
donc je suis très content bah oui c'est
les meilleurs maladie alors vous faisait
très branché chiffre à vous dites je
fais partie des 1 % d'écrivains qui
vivent de ce qu'ils écrivent ou dit
j'écris 3,7 manuscrit par an je suis
fasciné par les fils n'avait jamais rien
conclut donc ça me fascine alors vous
dites j'assiste à votre propre fécondité
avec beaucoup de passivité
vous dites j'écris quatre heures par
jour sinon je suis dangereuse et laurier
une phrase qui est terrible dans ce que
vous dites si vous dites le matin j'ai
besoin d'être traite des vaches à lait
juste et c'est monstrueux mais je trouve
ça moi même assez répugnant ce besoin
d'écrire retrouver sarah connor aussi
mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez rien est
sûr c'est un peu monstrueux et
complètement mais bon puis trouver le
moyen d'environ attendez vous à des
retraits enfants mais tous mais comme
disait beckett vous êtes donc à ce à
quoi sert un certain alors je pose des
problèmes parce que si vous continuez à
sortir un livre par an on n'est pas à
l'abri d'avoir à la fin comme ça 60 ce
qu'on me dit rien aucun projet d'avenir
je n'ai jamais voulu continuer à publier
tous les ans un livre je n'en sais rien
septembre 99
oui après j'en sais rien bon d'accord je
ne vois jamais ne me dérange pas mais en
face au vrai que ça fait quand même à la
sortie ça fera 60 bouquin c'est pas très
grave parce que c'est des tout-petits
libre ouais plus ce que vous publiez pas
puisque les innombrables est-ce que vous
avez pas peur vous vivez vraiment en
écriture comme on dit est ce que pas
peur de décrire sans vivre parce que tu
n'aies pas peur non j'ai une vie
amoureuse très intense qui me rattache
beaucoup apparemment oui alors vous êtes
toujours eu le désir d'un peu et c'est
pour ça que vous êtes devenu une vedette
aussi bien évidemment un peu des pâtés
de briller dès votre plus jeune âge non
détrompez vous gé on peut dire que de
l'âge de 10 ans à l'âge de 20 ans j'ai
été totalement seul
s'il n'y avait pas eu ma soeur qui est
pour moi un personnage essentiel il n'y
aurait donc là c'est un peu une revanche
là c'est pas ça je l'avais sincèrement
jamais songé à la moindre espèce de
célébrités en revanche ce qui est
certain qu'à l'âge de 23 ans j'ai pensé
à gagner ma vie parce que quand vous
êtes descendu j'ai fait une des
sensations du fuji yama vous allez
descendu en 40 minutes 3776 m c'est bien
se faire remarquer ça quand même non non
l'ex place passe par vous avez ainsi un
record en plus c'est un rapport un
record mondial mais l'exploit sportif
est toujours une chose qui m'a fasciné
quand même vous êtes comme
exhibitionniste vous exhibez votre
pathologie mais vous ne savez pas ce que
je n'existe pas ce qui fait que
finalement estimé samedi tout va bien
pour les télé ça vous êtes une bonne
cliente pas ce que vous dites quand
j'étais petit j'étais anorexique
c'est un refus de rentrer dans le mode
de me demander adultes vous dit
dès la puberté l'existence n'est qu'un
épilogue ce n'est pas très gai j'étais
un peu alcoolique parce que vous
finissiez des coupes de champagne à
l'ambassade asthmatiques
c'est pas très médiatique non c'est un
médiatiquement fin de cette accumulation
comme ça de 2 et alors vous êtes ski et
médiatique en revanche vous êtes
pourrite ofaj quoi se dire que vous
mangez du dd des fruits blé du roquefort
déjà un peu pour rire je ne vois
toujours pas ce que ceux-ci être
médiatique est pas si ça vous ça vous
rend intéressante par rapport à tous les
autres qui mange pas des trucs pourris
léger tout c'est un petit peu triste de
s'intéresser à moi pour ces raisons là
je pense que mes livres sont meilleures
raisons pour s'intéresser à moi dans mon
intérêt ça vole une version pas parler
de la pourriture si ça amuse les gens
mais personnellement je ne sais
simplement mon alimentation je ne trouve
pas c'est intéressant mais quand vous
donnerons vous demande votre vie vous
dites vomir disons que c'est une chance
qui m'arrive souvent en écrivant ouais
vous avez pas peur effectivement qu'on
parle plus de 2 de tout ça que de vos
bouquins je vais vous dire d'une
certaine façon même si je trouve ça tout
à fait lamentable
d'une certaine façon ça m'arrange bien
j'ai écrit dans l'hygiène de l'assassin
que parler d'un livre n'avait aucun sens
et je me laxiste à penser que parler
dans le même sens il faut le lire
alors plutôt que de vous expliquer oui
vous voyez mon livre est très profond à
ce que je vomis et puis c'est très bien
mais c'est très bien mais elle a en tout
cas vous êtes très particulière merci a
bientot on se connaissait pas comme ça
maintenant on se connaît et puis vous
viendront septembre 99 alors pour le le
suivant vous savez le titre déjà oui
mais je ne dis jamais elle avance à pas
de chance
à bientôt
on est sûr de ne rien rater de linars
dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un peu de
bleu